I mean,
part of the reason that the Germans
preferred Hitler to chaos was because they
felt that the order that Hitler
promised repressive as it was,
it was preferable to the chaos that
was likely to ensue in its absence.
What is it about chaos
that's so terrifying?
Second Nature said,
adopting a belief system of any sort
and imposing coherency on the world,
viewing it through the lens of that
explicit system disciplines your mind,
so for example,
to live in the absence of any stated
beliefs is hardly to live at all.
To live in the presence of a narrow minded
and extreme belief system is at least
to undergo the rigors,
both behavioral and intellectual
of coming to terms with the world.
From some perspective,
Nisha said the reason that
the modern mind such as it is,
was able to free itself from the past at
all was because it had first thoroughly
subjected itself to the tyranny
that was imposed by the past.
In consequence,
disciplined itself developed enough
discipline as a consequence of that
subordination to then break free of it
in all science of morals so far.
One thing was lacking.
Strange as it may sound.
The problem with morality itself,
what was lacking was any suspicion that
there was something problematic here.
Every society,
every functioning individual,
every functioning family,
every social unit has a moral code,
but they differ.
So what does that mean exactly?
Well,
it's complicated,
isn't it?
Because the fact of the
university quality of the code,
the fact of the code indicates that
the code or our code is necessary.
By the same token,
the fact that there's a multiplicity
of codes seems to suggest that the
particulars of a given code
aren't necessarily relevant,
and so nature says brilliantly,
I think we're faced with a problem.
No life without morality,
no absolute morality.
What do we do?
I wonder those things young observed
was that if you look at the structure of
stories,
you thought first there's a relationship
between stories and moral codes.
Well,
seems relatively straight forward,
doesn't it?
If you tell a simple story like a parable,
sometimes they're complex
to like an aesop fable safe.
What do you extract out from the story?
Moral?
What's the moral,
what's the implication of
this story for behavior?
Right?
So you tell a little story about someone
who acts out and given moral code and
that person does better or worse.
And the moral of this story
is if you act in this manner,
you will do better or worse,
proverbial knowledge.
We all tell stories,
they have identifiable structure.
You can tell that because it's a movie
studio in Hollywood can produce a movie
and people all over the
world will watch it.
People all over the world,
all over the world tell
stories to one another.
The plot elements seem similar.
Are the morals similar?
That's a more difficult question,
right?
We know that the details of morality
can vary from culture to culture.
Is there anything that doesn't vary from
culture to culture and why would you
want to find that?
Well,
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn thought that one
of the most important occurrences of the
20th century
or the Nuremberg trials and Nuremberg
trials brought the perpetual perpetrators
of the Nazi genocide to justice.
And it's easy to be cynical about that.
And perhaps you shouldn't be cynical
about it because the victors brought the
losers to trial.
And so of course the losers,
we're going to be tried from the
perspective of the winners moral code.
But Solzhenitsyn says,
well wait,
you know,
there's something more to this story.
At least there seems to be in that many
of the events that characterized the
Nazi atrocities were so awful outside of
intellectual argumentation because you
can provide an intellectual
argument for anything.
They were so awful that the
proper visceral embodied
response of any observer,
regardless of specific moral code,
should be repugnant,
period.
Such that encoded,
at least initially in international law,
genocide is a crime against humanity,
right?
No matter what the particulars of
your moral code so goes the logic.
You cannot construct a viable
moral code that enables genocide,
if not a logical impossibility.
And I think it is a logical impossibility.
It's an ethical impossibility.
And then you have to ask yourself,
and this is not precisely
and intellectual question,
does that seem credible to you?
Cause it seemed credible that there are
acts that are so terrible that no one,
regardless of their stated position,
should ever engage in them.
And if the answer is yes,
then I would say,
well,
if you haven't moved towards personal
except of acceptance of an ultimate up so
to speak,
you've certainly identified at least one
down that you don't want to approach.
And that's the beginnings
of the establishment of some
notion of absolute moral
authority.